can you believe Battle of Gods came out
10 years ago to celebrate the occasion I
went back and rewatched the movie and
while it still held up and the script
was just as solid as I remembered I
gotta say I was kind of Blown Away by
how much of a missed opportunity
everything after Battle of Gods was like
the movie Perfectly set up this big
reveal that there are many other
universes which is just ripe for
exploration more strong guys for Goku to
meet and so on and what did we follow it
up with a movie about Fraser coming back
a movie about Broly and a movie about
cell like yeah we got the Goku black
stuff in the tournament of power but
even that kind of spat on this
Multiverse business by immediately
establishing that Goku is one of the
strongest people in all of the
Multiverse just ah like so much wasted
opportunity but Battle of Gods is still
great though definitely give it a
re-watch if you can just for the
occasion in and of itself